Gibson keeps it in play as it comes to him on
the dump in zis tried to clear but it's kept in
by shley and a long shot from Morris he is in the
glove of John Gibson 16 seconds into the game an
optional morning skate this morning that's a big
addition to anaheim's lineup sure is you got a guy
that controls the neutral zone here's Nikolai
eers and a diving effort by the aforementioned
gutus to flex it over top of the net oh throughout
the lineup I mean you look at the number of goals
they're getting it from everywhere Mavish Cuts one
off got it to the net off the Stick Of Color who
inadvertently kicks it into the Anaheim zone now
has it along the boards as Dale contests him there
Dello got the pass across and Morris he turned
away Point flank by Gibson zigis up with it and
up left wing he goes cuts to the middle into the
Winnipeg Zone drops it off Isaac lundestrom goes
across Fresh Off the Bench it's leushin watched by
a follow he drops it back zis just pokes it to the
middle of the ice Ducks finish a change and the
pass well Off the Mark intended for mov he keeps
it alive for zigis who supports throws it in front
redirected right on by Henrik and a save by bro
swap Gibson did a good job there of sealing that
off and then great on the doorstep dying seconds
of the coincidental miners out of the box comes
vrono and Lowry and it's five on five hockey once
again Dello gets to it in the Anaheim zone for
Winnipeg kicked out by Gibson was Jamie Dale who
had an assist in a game against the Leafs on
Wednesday his long pass intercepted by Dylan
Samberg get him go Samberg went hard to the net a
couple of big saves from Gibson as he turns away
Lowry on the rebound as well below the goal line
the Jets get it back to Melo wipes looking for a
tip gab bardi spins Gibson around but couldn't
catch him while his back was turned that was a
fortunate moment for Anaheim there valard who had
the game winner last night in San Jose trying to
bring it to the front of the net puts it down low
shle changing direction now for eers always been a
thorn in the duck side he got it through Gibson
didn't see it until it hit him shot from Pon
had hit someone in front ends up behind the N but
it's found first by a apalo the former King brings
it out High Drops it off Dylan shot sticked
Away by Gibson in his last two games in fact
Ducks recovered possession Brock mcin with a bad
angle shot bris had a little trouble with it but
he grabs it off 17 games against Anaheim 16 points
10 of those are goals schmith got a shot through
it pops high in the air off the Stick of Gibson
and he and Henrik able to dig it loose and now a
restart for mnov Max Jones rink wide for zis pulls
it in fires and a glove save at him since they
acquired him over two years ago now McTavish leads
it into the Winnipeg Zone and a wrist shot off the
left boards from fowers handled really focusing on
eliminating any kind of a cross ice pass penalty
to Appleton expires as color brings it in fire
stick save bris McTavish across the line moves
to the right boards with him still possesses
looking for a trailer back at the line it's
Dale got it away SW kicks it out pick roll John in
Winnipeg I think when you talk about morisy it's
kind of the plight of the entire Winnipeg Jets
I said it at the top of our show Mark shley who
spent his entire career in Winnipeg's a load
to handle he just muscled that puck into the
Anaheim Zone Ducks counter back color kicks it
up nice little drop pass Mavis goes back hand he
scores
you this is just stick to of this plugging
away nice little dish into the middle but
look at that puck it won't sit down for
colorin he kicks it out to McTavish and
another big key who's right at the top
Radco Gus goes right to the top sets
up a little bit of a screen it's a seeing ey
shot that goes between the arm and the body of
brasis get to the net we said that was one of the
big keys Jets gave up the first goal last night
in San Jose and remember when these teams played
back in early December oh here's a good chance for
morrisy and again Gibson gets enough of it right
back through the slot and he missed his intended
target with it and boy the Ducks had numbers
but the outlet pass off the skate of zis now
he's joined by lundestrom Off the Bench and his
shot turned away by bris out High drale finds a
little open Ice Fowler all the way behind the net
now brings it back out his defense partner Dale
with a snapshot got a deflection in front from
lundestrom final minute of play in the opening
frame to the line Dello sleeps sweeps it across
and a blocker Save On morrisy by Gibson by a
follow Sam Burke from behind the Winnipeg net
moves it ahead it's broken up and a quick shot
by silverberg kicked aside by brois bonus
first became the head coach there were many
that thought neither of those players would stay
mikov waiting for somebody to join him just takes
the shot one of the few weaknesses this Jets team
has they're not a great Faceoff team there's a
tip and a save by Gibson and another safe as it
was tonado right on the doorstep protecting the
bottom of the net but the top as well here's
the redirect Gibson in good position see good
patience just stays down over skate Ed it as
to get onside heers gives it back to him heon
across the top Dylan to shley high slot shot in
and out of the glove of Gibson and cleared away
Jets still possess eers snaps it across shley had
a little trouble but still possesses room for eers
score and the Jet's best player has tied the
game yeah a little bit of confusion in the
defensive Zone and Nikolai eers finds himself
with a lot of space and a little bit of time
and Mentor trip they're calling it for the Jets
and they're celebrating up in the private box but
good play by valard well look at the screen
in front I mean there's no chance for John
Gibson perfect shot just inside the
post but Gibson couldn't pick it
up due to that core injury and here's a
turnover at center it's McTavish who busts
into the Winnipeg zone Great pass to colog CL
save BR what a stop Mavish delivered well that
was going in yeah you're right fower and Dale
play catch pass up the middle of the ice to
McTavish he loses an edge and the puck Samberg the
defenseman joins The Rush with namestnikov pulls
up the trailer Schmidt right down Main Street
he scores Nate Schmidt and the had their first
lead of the night Ducks had a good opportunity
on the rush and you could see Mason just loses
an edge and an outnumbered attack and it's the
late man coming in Schmid makes a good shot see
where this goes does it go underneath the glove
of John Gibson y just underneath the glove over
the pad unable to pick it up on the other side
Tony n sweeps it down down low Baron from behind
the net back hands it right in front great kick
save by Gibson on Jansen fby andri joins him on
a short-handed Rush two on two but then he'll
peel back in change as namestnikov and color
get entangled former teammates in Tampa Bay Neer
Rider brings it in back for NES nikov snaps it
across and Cole Peretti scores his team leading
fifth on the power play and the Jets go up 3-1
Roy NE Rider makes a great pass asn't it he
drills it they just turned 22 on New Year's
Day 10th overall pick you see why this last year
of Junior silverberg turns with it back hands it
across oh to one knee lundestrom couldn't get
it by and it's stuck on the right side of the
net bro swah can't get it it's cleared out by
the Jets who will win this one here tonight